MCFERRYSON THE LINESMEN.
SANFORD, TRAPPED BACK,
CONNOR BROWN WITH A FIRST SHOT
AND IT'S INTO THE
THE END OF NOVEMBER, BEGINNING
OF DECEMBER.
>> John: A SHOT S KELLY
OF THE ICE TO GET THIS ONE GOING
IN THE NATION'S A
HIGHGH
PIECE OF IT.
IT'S CLEARED TO CENTRE, ROMANOV
WILL FEED IT BACK FOR CHIAROT. Y
THE STOP, BIG REBOUND.
ROMANOV GOES AFTER IT,
MURRAY WILL PLAY IT OFF FOR NICK
HOLDEN.I KNOW NOT AN INCREDIBLYG
OPPONENT BUT HE LOOKED THE BEST
I'VE
>> Gary: THECE TO BE
TO STICK WITH THE SENS AND HABS.
>> John: THANK TO PLAY WITH
ENERGY, HE WANTS TO PLAY LIKE
THEY'RE ENJOYING PLAYING
TO CENTRE.
METE BEING WATCHED BY ANDERSON.
SUZUKI TRIED TO SAVE
MADE BY MURRAY.
GOT THE PAD ACROSS ON ARTTURI
LEHKON
DEFENSIVELY, PENALTY
HELD BACK BY WIDEMAN, ONE HAND
ON THE STICK GOT IT T
DEFENCE INCLUDING ARTEM ZUB.
>> Gary: SOMEONE WILL PENALTY.
THE MONTREAL CANADIENS PENALTY
KILLING CHUNKY, NOWO
FROM HIS KNEES SEND THE PASSWHEN
ACROSS.
JOSH ANDERSON OFF A LEG.
TO
BE THE MOST SPREAD OUT, AND A
GOOD JOB BY THE SENATORS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IS STUTZLE TRYING O
SETTLE THE PECULIAR DOWN AND
HANDS IT OFF FOR ROMANOV.
JARRED LOOSE AND AWAY IT AHEAD.
ENNIS TRY TO GO CATCH UP TO IT,.
FORMENTON GOT IT DOWN TO
WITH A NICE LITTLE SHOVEL PASS
DUMPED BACK IN, THAT GOT AWAY
FROM MURRAY BEHIND
SLOT AND HE UNLOA Gary: 4 40TH Y
OF YOUR 50TH BIRTHDAY IF YOU
WANT TO PUTIT.
LOOK AT HIM SITTING OUTROUGHT IY
FORMENTON.
GET
THAT MONKEY OFF QUICKLY AS HE GS
IT AROUND
PICKING UP ANYBODY, AND THEN ALL
GOING TO STING. THIS HOFFMAN SD
SHOT AND GETS IT IN THE